leute was geht und herzlich willkommen
zum heutigen video ich bin weil luca wir
vielleicht im hintergrund erkennt und
wir machen heute etwas komplett neues
wird zwar machen wir eine indoor fußball
challenge luca hat hier schon seit
ewigkeiten hat diesen kleinen fußball 30
problem und wir machen da jetzt zur
wende verändert und wir machen zwei
videos einzige du mich auch bei meinen
liga werden wir zielschießen machen
ja wir machen
sie schießen vielleicht die zur
bestrafung vielleicht nicht dran wir
müssen uns überlegen wo machen wir die
linie auf der pflanzen winterlichen ding
seit jahrzehnten die er genau fünf
schüsse der flachen trifft gewinnt
bewusst linie weniger wahrscheinlich ist
eine flasche nach linie bahn linien von
last light 45 genau wissen will
forscher
doch erstens seiner zweitheimat
getroffen hier zu rang eins kann ich den
rücken erzählen lassen
ich drücke das finde ich es verdiene nun
kriegt die bestrafung dies vielleicht
geben
flaschen nummer 1 weil jeder patient
erhält jeder fünfte schloss und kirche
welche für bon hatte wobei ich will sich
es geht und 2455 hinzugewinnen sonst
gibt es noch keines zu schwer ist ich
habe jetzt zwei
junge herr hängst du was zur hölle war
es gerade das fünf mal nicht getroffen
und ich hätte es trifft sich gut als
videos erst fünf minuten lang
ok alle teams unentschieden leute damit
muss man wenn man professionell youtuber
ist rechnen und logischerweise machen
wir jetzt ja da unten eine art vorwahl
und wir beschiessen wieder von da vorne
das hier ist die linie gegenseitig mit
diesem ball auf das tor und da unten
wird einen guten torwart sitzen und
probiert den ball zu halten bis einer
verliert dann gibt es vielleicht einfach
aus rhade
wie kann unentschieden trennen
wie war nochmal regel mit ab
geschossen habe seid ihr bereit für die
vielleicht beschaffung war es schon
nicht betroffen
es soll frauen und was für ein frisches
video schon wieder gucken und der
immerhin haben wir viel zu wenig zeiten
viel zu viel video ideen lassen live
eine superchance nach seiner bestrafung
martinstraße sich sofort waren draußen
um belohnungen man mit wasser abspritzte